the dulcet tones of mike florio the host
of pft live
the creator of pro football talk and
profootballtalk.com
and the author of playmakers which comes
out next week where all books are sold
but you can get it and pre-order it
right now where all books are sold you
go on amazon you get 20 off mike florio
here on the rich eisen show let's jump
into it here is it a bad sign that
they're already offering it for 20 off
before it's even out somebody asked me
that it's like well you know i don't
know i just want them to sell whatever
it takes all that matters to me i got my
advance i just want them to sell at this
point mike you're you're you're you're
talking to somebody whose 2007 book
could have been acquired in a dollar
store by 2008 so um you're in good shape
all right good you're in good shape i
think you're in great great shape
i still haven't i found it on the shelf
i still have it what my access
yes it's
it's quite the tone it's so dated now
it's insane it was about a two-day draft
and uh and uh you know in the the hall
of fame that was just barely in the in
their new stadium it's crazy
it wasn't even a nighttime draft in 2000
correct yeah it was just a two-day draft
back in the day
so uh let's get just hop right into it
in uh what's going on with the packers
and how this all came together best you
can tell well
something that i sent you just minutes
before we found out about
roger's contract and something that
dawned on me this morning on pft live
the tremendous leverage that aaron
rodgers had over the packers with that
cap number of 46.66 million second only
to matt ryan who has a 47 million dollar
cap number and the packers are projected
to be or were as the case may be 30
million over the cap for 2022
they needed to either dump all of his
salary 26 million in change by trading
him or dramatically reduce that cap
number from the salary reduce the salary
signing bonus etc spread it out over
time they needed to do one or the other
by next wednesday at 4 pm eastern when
all teams have to be in compliance with
the caps so
they really needed aaron to do something
and if he wanted to push this thing all
the way to the limit he could have just
said i'm fine with my contract i'm ready
to honor my contract and i think that
leverage helped him get
this deal that
is either four years 200 or 5 years 224
we'll get the details soon and the devil
is always in the details you hear
different bits and pieces but until you
can actually dig into the numbers it's
impossible to know what it all means but
it's going to be the richest contract in
nfl history and i think it's going to
have the flexibility that he can walk
away whenever he wants without a major
financial penalty
for for him or for the team is what
you're saying for him
now and it could just be they take the
signing bonus and they defer the
payments into future years so he doesn't
have to go through that awkward step of
paying money back but whatever the case
may be they're trying to set it up i
believe from what i've heard as him
having full flexibility to walk away
whenever he wants and not have that sort
of damocles financially hanging over his
head or he can play it out all the way
through and he has 22 years with the
packers which is an incredible number
and certainly since we thought
22 uh the number would be the the
the league year in which he would have
to be gone because it was jordan love's
job for sure the packers were absolutely
gonna go to him and back-to-back mvp
years after jordan love gets drafted
changes everything it's amazing it
really is amazing
a draft pick
light a fire under someone's ass
the way that the jordan love pick did
with aaron rodgers and you know it's
funny i wonder how much of that
was intentional because i know the year
before when tyler dunn was still at
bleacher report and he had the article
about all the dysfunction between rogers
and mike mccarthy
it was mark murphy the ceo of the team
who said either in that article or after
the fact you know if this light's a fire
for some people good and it worked they
had a great year in 2019 they got to the
nfc championship game and i just can't
help but wonder whether there's a little
mad scientist slash puppet master from
murphy with this love thing because
we're covered either way either love is
going to become our next guy or rogers
is going to have a fire lit under his
ass and we're going to get great
performance out of him and that's where
they are and now they have to figure out
what to do with jordan love
well what do you think
he's gone right they have to
because dunn is is it the agent who who
did this deal for rogers it now has to
turn to love right and say what what
what what about him here's the best
litmus test if nathaniel hackett the
former offensive coordinator of the
packers and now the head coach of the
broncos
does or doesn't want jordan love after
two years with him and if hackett
doesn't make a play for him that is the
red flag for anyone else out there who
doesn't have a pre-existing relationship
with jordan love because that means this
guy's not ready now i think the broncos
are probably going to aim higher as they
move on from aaron rodgers maybe they
try to make a run at russell wilson
maybe they go after i don't know where
you go after russell wilson on that list
i think it's a long drop from him to
jimmy g but you know at some point you
have to consider the possibility of
jordan love if nathaniel hackett thinks
he's got the goods and if they go
straight after jordan love then the
message is hey maybe this guy can play
and we know the broncos are otherwise
set up to have a competitive team mike
florio here on the rich eisen show and
let's talk about how roger's decision
affects the quarterback carousel it
slows considerably right don't you think
well but we were waiting for him
to make his views known and what it does
now it clears him off the table so these
other teams that are looking for
quarterbacks can start
making their plans and implementing
their plans if the broncos are indeed
willing to give the seahawks a phone
call and i think russell wilson's in
play i think last week when pete carroll
says we have no intention to trade
russell wilson the exact same thing rick
spielman said nine years ago about percy
harvin right before he traded percy
harvin at the seahawks no intention to
trade is a signal we're not trading him
under any set of circumstances means
we're not trading him we have no
intention to trade him means if you want
to give us a call and make us an offer
then maybe you can change our intention
and i i think that he is in play i think
the seahawks realize that they're going
to trade him now or next year they're
going to choose between trading him or
giving him a high-end market value
contract because he always does his next
deal with one year left on his current
one so it won't surprise me if the
broncos turned to russell wilson or
whoever else would have been thinking
about
aaron rodgers pivots to russell wilson
and you got some of these other guys out
there whose value goes up now jimmy g's
value goes up mitch trubisky we've been
hearing all this talk about him all of a
sudden swooping in and being a starting
quarterback somewhere i i think that
to the extent the vikings are ambivalent
about kirk cousins and who really knows
how they feel maybe he's in play for a
trade now that you take aaron rodgers
off the market so i think it's going to
create a greater demand for some of
these veteran quarterbacks especially
with the perception
that the draft classic quarterback isn't
as strong as it's been in recent years
well and then that said mike floria was
one week ago at this time i'm holding in
my hands uh on very nice kyle murray
stationary the greatest agent manifesto
since jerry maguire's um and now we look
to the gram and we see
um all of kyler murray's missing posts
that were removed um returned they're
back
i guess he did in fact archive them wow
he did in fact archive them or he's got
an intern that uh had to put them all
back on his instagram page
so
what do you think of what's going on
with arizona what is going on with
arizona in columbia i think last week
when they announced the new deals for
coach cliff kingsbury and steve kim and
they run through 2027 in theory
some of that may not be guaranteed we
never heard how much kingsbury is making
and if there's any chest thumping to do
about the amount of a contract the agent
usually finds a way to do it either
directly or by leaking it so that's
that's a sign that it's not top of
market or close to it but
once you make the bed with cliff
kingsbury
you're you're
compelled to keep kyler murray because
the common thread between the two guys
is the agent so i think by extending
kingsbury that's laying the foundation
to do a deal with murray and maybe he
has been sufficiently placated that
something's going to be done now i saw
someone suggest recently and i can't
remember who it was because i always
like to give credit where credit's due
the idea that
if this thing's going to blow up it
needs to blow up before
free agency in the draft that he wants
to be traded
at a time when he can jump on the
quarterback carousel especially now that
you take aaron rodgers off of it if he's
not going to stay in arizona let's do it
now let's not screw around and have an
impasse drive us apart later but if he's
put that stuff back on instagram i mean
to the extent it was significant that it
was gone it's significant that it's back
and we know that's how 24 year olds send
messages so i think that's significant
it tells me he's heard something from
the cardinals that makes him think
they're going to get him taken care of
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
let's get to calvin ridley which would
have been uh the topic du jour uh for
this entire news cycle uh on peacock and
every other um sports um talk radio
slash television network
um i'll give you the floor and what you
thought of that the suspension of calvin
ridley
i i was
i was stunned by the duration
of the suspension
based upon the conduct that he admitted
it was stupid it was dumb
it was avoidable you don't make bets
with your own phone and it makes me
wonder how many guys out there are
making bets through a friend
never having their fingerprints on it
directly but just giving cash to the
friend or taking cash from the friend if
the bets are successful only five guys
in nfl history have been suspended for
gambling surely more guys have done it
than that
i just hope that the nfl eventually
because there will be and eventually
there will be other scandals whether
it's people gambling when they shouldn't
or
mishandling of inside information
whether it's truth about injuries game
plans
first 15 scripted plays anything that
would be sensitive in the wrong hands
people taking that and turning it into
cash even without betting just the fact
that you are taking money or something
else of value from someone who wants
that information these are things the
nfl has to guard against and i hope that
they just don't look for someone that
they can
point to and say we nailed this guy
because ridley fell into their lap i've
been saying all day it's not like
they're walking around with the big
sherlock holmes magnifying glass right
it fell into their lap how aggressive
are they going to be
looking for others how aggressive are
they going to be enforcing rules
regarding the use of inside information
how aggressive are they going to be
about the injury report which is
worthless at this point tom brady played
all of 2020 with a torn mcl in his knee
and they hit it the whole year that's
where the risk also lies for the nfl and
also on top of everything else what do
you do about steven ross if you're going
to suspend calvin ridley for a full year
because he placed a few parlays and and
and always bet on his team to win what
do you do about the owner who allegedly
offered his coach a hundred thousand
dollars per game that he lost
see it's it's not that they better on
them to win it's the fact that he bet on
him at all like you know and again i
agree but i'm just
telling his coach to lose no no no
that's what i'm saying for sure and and
and um
you know i am waiting to hear what comes
of that investigation you know and and
because to me
uh if i'm seeing videos out there and i
saw him on twitter i think a member of
our uh
media world uh
erased his
um posting of a video of calvin ridley
you know oddly running out of bounds or
stop
running towards an end zone in weird
ways just weird weird situations of
calvin ridley on the field and that is
now in light of all this
you know thought to be maybe um
you know a donaghy moment for the nfl in
a way
um that that if that is what we're
seeing and how harmful that is i mean
and the league knows how harmful that is
how how harmful is it to have an owner
say i'm i'm i'm offering you 600 you
know six figures to lose games that's
beyond significant and you even said
that you were surprised at how
you know um strident roger goodell
sounded when the subject was brought up
during the super bowl at his press
conference well in the other subject
that roger goodell addressed regarding
the latest allegations against daniel
snyder as to workplace misconduct the
notion that teams can't be trusted to
investigate themselves
at what point do we say the league may
not be able to investigate itself when
there's a scandal that would be
sufficiently
harmful to the league if it's proven to
be true is stephen ross if this is true
is it in the league's interest to stand
up and tell the world hey one of our
owners was engaged in the kind of
corruption that entailed him telling the
team to lose and
undermining the legitimacy of the games
and undermining the legitimacy of the
bets and we're going to open ourselves
up to a class action brought by anyone
who bet on
the dolphins in any of the jurisdictions
where wagering was legal in 2019 either
bet on them to win straight up or bet on
them to cover the spread go ahead and
sue us because we're giving you the road
map to proving that we're liable at what
point
does the league
and i don't know how it handles this
because there's no third party oversight
and rich i really think that's where
this ends up some way somehow there's
going to be a scandal in one of the
major sports that is in bed with the
sport sports books at some point over
the next five 10 15 years that results
in congress creating a federal agency
that oversees pro sports the same way
the securities and exchange commission
oversees stock trading i think it's
inevitable it's just going to take one
scandal to light the fuse to get
congress to do it
[Music]
what's your thoughts before i let you go
on who the first overall pick of the
draft is i have daniel jeremiah coming
up next hour i'm going to ask him the
same thing coming out of the combine
what do you think well i'll defer to him
but it sure sounds like it's going to be
one of these tackles look if the
quarterbacks aren't there at the top
then it's either the guys who affect the
quarterbacks or the guys who protect the
quarterbacks that's your next most
important job because once you have a
quarterback and we saw it with joe
burrow in the super bowl they didn't
have a guy to protect him
the rams had a guy to affect him and
when jamar chase was running wide open
down the right sideline because his feet
got tied up with jalen ramsey and ramsey
fell down burrow couldn't get the ball
to him because he was swallowed up by
donald so
i i've you know again it depends on what
the jaguar's priority is but if you want
the most out of trevor lawrence you got
to be looking at one of those tackles so
i guess now with rogers with his
decision it's it's like what the jc
jackson where he goes tyron matthew i
mean like is that the what what
brady makes his power play to go back to
the 49ers that's what we got to do next
we got an interest in you know getting
people interested and clicking and
reading and watching tom brady the 49ers
that's my next
okay well you know as as all of uh rich
eisen show great ideas uh uh
are born we just winged it yesterday
here on the program we came up with a
new segment called the the tb12 heat
check um
from zero to 12. uh zero is he's
running lines and doing jello shots at
rita moreno's house he's got no shot
coming back like he's not even thinking
about it and 12 is he's definitely
coming back where where are where are
you right now mike florio on the tb12 he
check 11.997
i i guess look at his
oh yeah look he retired from the
buccaneers he didn't retire from the nfl
he retired from the buccaneers and i
know bruce arians is
trying to create the idea that they're
not going to let him go to another team
and they want five first-round picks
it's not bruce's call
i think that tom brady makes the call to
someone named glazer and explains i i
came there under a two-year contract i
signed a one-year extension last year
for cap purposes i fulfilled my two
years please let me go please let me
continue my career where i want to and
it's going to be hard for the buccaneers
to push back against that
so
allow a little bit a little bit wiggle i
i really do when you look at everything
he's saying and he started this they
can't blame us they can blame us for a
lot of stuff right they can't blame us
for this six days after he retired he
goes never say never on his podcast and
he says i don't know how i'm going to
feel in june which reminded me
eerily of what brett favre said to david
letterman in april 2008 which made me
think that he was coming back something
along the lines of something's bound to
happen when training camp rolls around
and i feel like tom brady tom brady
cannot walk away 5 000 passing yards and
he said before i don't want to turn on
the tv and see a bunch of guys playing
and i say wow they suck i can do it
better and the only way he's going to
avoid that this year is either come back
or not watch football at all and then
what better way to just reassert his
dominance right than with rogers in his
50 million dollar a year contract he
comes back and and does it
but 49ers the super bowl favorite if he
goes there are they not well i think you
so are the bucks don't you think i mean
so pretty much anybody where he goes i
know obviously we need to see how the
bucks handle free agency and things of
that nature but don't you think i mean
just add tom and suddenly he's he's
definitely makes a team a super bowl
contender i think there's a handful of
teams but i think the 49ers are an even
better super bowl contender
with him because look at how good
they've been
with a guy who's a major step down and
let's be fair i mean jimmy garoppolo is
good enough to start and he'll probably
start for someone this year and be the
difference between 4 and 13 and 8-9 but
he's not a super bowl winner he's not a
championship-level quarterback brady on
that 49ers team and i'm sure the 49ers
regret saying no to him two years ago he
was their first choice and they said no
thank you this is their chance to
rectify that and finally get kyle
shanahan a super bowl trophy well i
appreciate you you're you're the first
guest to take part in the new segment
tb12 heat check so thank you for lending
some legitimacy to this inanity i
greatly appreciate it
take care good luck on the book that
comes out next week i'm more than happy
to have you back on uh when when it
comes out i'll help uh whatever in any
way i can appreciate it
that's uh mike floyer oh there he goes
there's mike floyer everybody uh amazon
you get it now uh for twenty percent off
please
sold what the heat checkers book ah both
okay very good
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here